it's time for drew's a love bug where we
explore
all things love from dating to marriage
and certified dating coach
and our friend of the show demona
hoffman is here and she and i have a lot
to say today
hi demona hey drew
looking beautiful on the inside and out
as always
thank you i'm ready to help people in
love
i know and you're you have been happily
married for a long time
and so and you know i'm a divorcee and i
love that we
both come at it from different points of
view but i always
love your advice it is so salient it is
just i'm so happy to be a partner
in this with you um because we're all
contending with relationships
no matter what absolutely and so
absolutely
and it can be really complicated if we
make it complicated
but i like to make it easy and like you
i love love
i absolutely love your approach and it
should be easy
and actually okay we're gonna get right
into questions because i'm just
i could talk about this all day long
okay shayna is here and she has a
question about online dating
hi so i jump back on the dating app
hinge which i had success with in the
past
not really having success making those
quality connections
how do i move forward with initiating
the initial call or virtual date without
being super weird
shayna it's only weird if we make it
weird you it sounds like you're stuck in
what i call the texting trap it's really
easy to think that you can filter
through all of these messages
online but i want to help you break out
of that
and you can do that by inviting
an invitation and you it doesn't have to
be weird you can just say
i would love to tell you more about that
when we meet for a date and then
your man is invited to pick up the phone
or take you out
on a date because we can sure waste a
lot of time so your love lesson shayna
is to not spend more than one week
after you match with someone before you
do a phone call
or a date that's it that'll save you a
lot of time i love that
that is super amazing to get a goal and
a timeline and
alex if it's any consolation i tried a
dating app and i got the same thing no
follow through
so damona i like your timeline um shayna
i'm so sorry alex is the one who is
actually coming here
we have a question from the fellas um
alex is struggling to find the one
alex what's your question hey drew
barrymore uh
so i feel like i'm mr undateable
i've been burned a lot in the past and
after a while it uh
you know it's hard to stay the nice guy
um so my question is
you know how can i trust and get back
into the dating process again
after like a recent heartbreak or
rejection you know am i undateable
i don't think so drew i think everyone
is datable and i think
nice guys win i married one i did this
whole dating plan called
operation date nice guys i'll tell you
about it another time but here's the
thing alex
what happens when we have heartbreak and
when we have
we have relationships that don't work
out we bring that pain with us to the
next
relationship and we put up these walls
that prevent you from really being
yourself
and i don't know if you heard alex but i
would say that vulnerability
is the new black it's very sexy so when
you bring your whole self
into the room that's when you'll be able
to make your match so here's your love
lesson
alex i would say try to take down those
walls without
worrying about the ultimate outcome
because the ones who are not right
for you absolutely they will run for the
hills but the one who is right we're
only looking for one she will see all
those wonderful qualities about you
i totally agree demona and you know what
i promise you this alex
nice guys do finish last so enjoy being
single because one day in an instant
it'll be gone
and you will find the girl who realizes
that when it's nice
and less drama and really functioning
and you guys have to work at things
but it feels really right that is where
we all end up
and that is the right place to be i
believe
[Music]